اهلا بكم تنفذ اسرائيل منذ ليله الاثنين
غارات جويه على غزه خلفت شهداء ومصابين
كما اعلنت عدم استبعاد اي خيار عسكري بما
في ذلك التوغل البري في القطاع لاجب حماس
على وقف اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه المدن
الاسرائيليه من جهتها توعدت المقاومه
بتوسيع دائره استهدافها للعمق الاسرائيلي
اذا لم توقف اسرائيل حملتها على قطاع غزه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين ما
دلالات هذا التصعيد الجديد في المواجهه
بين اسرائيل
وحماس وما هي خيارات الطرفين لاداره هذا
التصعيد
يتصعد تدريجيا نسق القصف الاسرائيلي على
غزه مخلفا شهداء وجرحى من جهتها تبنت
كتائب القسام اقتحام قاعده زكيم العسكريه
الاسرائيليه على شواطئ عسقلان في مؤشر على
احتدام حده المواجهه بين اسرائيل
والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه غره ليليه ونهار لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه قتل وجرحه ودمار
وتظل اسرائيل تقول ان عمليه الجرف الصامد
ليست اعلان حرب فماذا تكون اذا اهي عمليه
عسكريه محدوده لاسكات المتطرفين اليهود
الذين يضغطون على نتنياهو لشن حرب ضد حركه
حماس بعد حادثه اختطاف وقتل ثلاثه شبان
اسرائيليين ام ان التصعيد قد يولد تصعيدا
اكبر يجر المنطقه الى حرب اخرى يعتمد جيش
الاحتلال الان على الطيران الحربي
لاستهداف مواقع ومنازل داخل غزه على حدود
القطاع يذكر المشهد ما سبق حرب الرصاص
المسكوب في عام 2008 القوات البريه على
اهبه الاستعداد لاي توغل في غزه استدعي
عشرات الالاف من جنود الاحتياط كل هذه
الاجراءات ومصطلح الحرب غير مستخدم من قبل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي تصر على انها
تريد تلقين حماس درسا قاسيا في الحقيقه تل
ابيب ومنذ ابريل الماضي تبحث عن ذريعه
لافشال اتفاق المصالحه بين حما
و الرئيس ابو مازن في موقف حرج امام
الفلسطينيين ولكن لماذا بدات عمليه الجرف
الصامد بعد مفاوضات بين اسرائيل وحماس
بواسطه المخابرات المصريه بشان صيغه جديده
لاتفاق وقف اطلاق النار الذي يعود الى عام
2012 ا هيي محاوله من تلبيب من اجل الحصول
على الصيغه التي تريدها تحت ضغط السلاح
اسرائيل لم تنتصر في حرب غزه عام 2008
لذلك لا ترغب رسميا في حرب اخرى تكسب حماس
والفلسطينيين تعاطف المجتمع
الدولي ولكن هل ستنجح السلطه الفلسطينيه
في اقناع الامريكيين والغربيين بالضغط على
اسرائيل لوقف اعتداءاتها المتكرره وماذا
لو تحولت الاعتداءات الى حرب مفتوحه في
شرق اوسط ملتهب
اصلا معنا في هذه الحلقه من غزه الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي مصطفى الصواف ومن القدس
الاني روبنشتاين استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه العبريه نرحب بضيفي نبدا من القدس
وداني روبنشتاين
لماذا اختارت اسرائيل مره اخرى التعامل مع
قطاع غزه بهذا
الاسلوب
عشان بح حكومه اسرائيل بتقول في تصريحات
كل العمليه عمليه اختتاف وقتل هذول
الثلاثه اغتيال ضل الثلاثه الشباب
الاسرائيليه هذا يعني الحماس حركه حماس
تخمل لمس
بالنسبه لاسرائيل حركه حماس هي هي عدو وفي
حرب مستمر مع حركه الحماس مع حركه الحماس
هي ما في اتمال لمشاركه حركه الحماس
بالحكومه الفلسطينيه اوي مفاوضات مع
اسرائيل ولكن في النهايه ما دخل حكومه
الوفاق او اختطاف المستوطنين بقطاع غزه
ككل كان هذا يعني هذا هذا م بيمل
للمسؤوليه هذا حركه خماس هدول الشباب اللي
عملوا الارها الارهاب وقتل المستوطنين
ثلاثه المستوطنين كانوا من من من حركه
حماس اما بالنسبه لاسرائيل حركه حماس تخمل
المسؤوليه اما مبدئيا حركه حماس هي
العدوفي اسرائيل لمصيره السلام واسرائيل
ما تعترف اي مفاوضات مع حركه حما حماس ومع
الحكومه الفلسطينيه الى حركه حماس هي جز
على تجزم من من الحكومه الفلسطينيه هذا
يعني موقف اسرائيل حكومه اسرائيل حكومه
يمين وفي يعني هذا هذا موقف الحكومه
الاسرائيليه موقف مبدئيا بالنسبه للحماس
في شروط الحماس في الشرط الاول اترا
اسرائيل والشرط الثاني هذا وقف الارهاب
وهذا نحن
والحماس لا لا يستطيع اي اي اتراب في
اسرائيل وهذا معروف هذا نحن نحن ن نحن
نعرف هذا هذا شيء واضح مشانها نعم في في
هذه الحاله سيد مصطفى سواف هل هل التصعيد
الجديد فرض عمليا على حماس في في هذا في
هذا
الظرف يعني اعتقد ان هذا التصعيد ال الذي
يشهده قطاع غزه في هذه الفتره قد سبق وان
هددت به القياده الاسرائيليه
سواء كان السياسيه او العسكريه وانا في
ظني ان هذا الاجرام الذي تقوم به قوات
الاحتلال وهذه المجازر التي ترتكب بحق
المدنيين في قطاع غزه هي تعبير عن العقليه
الدمويه التي تتولى الحكم داخل هذا الكيان
الارهابي واعتقد ان قطاع غزه عندما يتحمل
او تحمله قوات الاحتلال مسؤوليه اختفاء
المستوطنين الثلاثه وقتلهم بروايه رائيه
حتى هذه اللحظه دون ان تعترف حماس او اي
من القوى الفلسطينيه مسؤوليه عنها هو
تبرير واضح لهذا العدوان وهذا ربما يجعل
البعض يخرج بعيدا عن سياق اتهام حركه حماس
وانها عمليه مدبره من قبل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي حتى تجد مبررا للقيام بهذا
العدوان الدموي الارهابي بحق ابناء الشعب
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه نعم ولكن في هذه
الحاله سيد صواف تعتقد بان اسرائيل تتعامل
مع قطاع غزه وكانه هو مقر القياده العامه
لحماس وبالتالي تريده ان يدفع ثمن كل ما
جرى هذا بالتاكيد يعني طالما ان اسرائيل
تنظر الى قطاع غزه على انه حركه حماس وهذه
نظره خاطئه هي اساسا لتبرير العدوان قطاع
غزه يشمل كل القوى والفصائل الفلسطينيه
والانتماءات السياسيه ولكن على ما يبدو ان
العدو الاسرائيلي يرى في المقاومه عنصرا
مهم
في استقراره وبقائه وهو يرى انه من
الضروري القضاء على المقاومه الفلسطينيه
حتى يستقر هذا الكيان و تسمح له الفرصه
ولغيره من ممن يساند هذا العدو الى تصفيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه جميعهم يدركون بان بقاء
المقاومه في قطاع غزه وفي الضفه الغربيه
وفي كل فلسطين هو نذير شؤم على استمرار
وجود هذا الكيان على الارض الفلسطينيه
المغتصبه فلذلك هم يحاولون الان تجفيف
منابع المقاومه بل استئصالها من الارض
الفلسطينيه وهذا هو العدوان الثالث ربما
في اقل من عده سنوات 2008 2009 2012 وهذا
العدوان الثالث ولم تحقق اسرائيل اهدافها
رغم المجازر التي ارتكبت والتي كان اخرها
مجزره عائله كوارع في مدينه خانيونس نعم
اشرت سيد صواف الى حادثه اختطاف
المستوطنين الثلاثه وكذلك السيد د
روبنشتاين اشار الى هذه الحادثه هنا اسال
السيد روبنشتاين الا
يعتبر ما يجري الان في غزه وكانه استغلال
مبالغ فيه من قبل اسرائيل لحادثه اختطاف
المستوطنين حتى على فرض ان فعلا حماس هي
من يقف وراء هذا الاختطاف وهذا ما لم
تتبناه الحركه
رسميا هذا ليس استغلال اسرائيل نحن نعرف
كل يوم خلال كل السنه اللي فاتت كل يوم في
صواريخ في صواريخ من غزه احيانا من الحماس
احيانا من الجهاد الاسلامي او من من من من
اي اي اي حركه فلسطينيه هذا ليس مشان مشان
مشان حكومه اس هذا ليس مقاومه هذا هذا
عمليه ارهابيه يعني صواريخ على مدن
اسرائيل على مدنيين في كل جنوب اسرائيل
على حدود اسرائيل هذا بالنسبه لنا بالنسبه
للحكومه اسرائيل هذا هذا عمليه ارهابيه من
البدايه للاخيره هذا ارهابي و بالنسبه لنا
هذا ليس مربوط لاختطاف و للعمليه اللي
كانت في مع هدول الثلاثه اللي نقتلو اما
اما هذا يعني هذا فرصه لاسرائيل للسقوط
اسرائيل تريد سقوط كل سيطره الحماس ال ق
تعه غزه اما في خدود للقوه في حدود للقوه
في اسرائيل يعني ما في احتمال ل لاقتحام
لاقتحام غازه مع الجنود ومع الدبابات عشان
كل غزه هي هي عزيك
و وما في احتمال للمشاع ولل دبابات عشان
يقتحموا وعشان يدخلوا ل للغاز وهذا
المشكله بالنسبه بالنسبه لاسرائيل عشان
عشان هيك في غارات جويه وفي مداف
وهذا في اليوم نح في امل للوسط مصريه ووق
قبل الحديث عن الوساط المصريه سيد قبل
الحديث عن الوساط المصريه سيد نعم معذره
قبل الحديث عن الوساطه المصريه سيد
روبنشتاين
قبل هذه المواجهه الاخيره او هذه هذه
الغارات على غزه كان هناك نوع من الهدوء
يعني قبل حادثه اختطاف المستوطنين تقريبا
لم تكن هناك صواريخ ولم يكن هناك غارات
اسرائيليه الا فيما فيما ندر لماذا لماذا
الان قرار اسرائيلي بجعل الغارات اكثر
تكثيفا وامكانيه توسيع العمليات على
غزه كان كان اولا كان كل الوقت كل السنه
اللي فاتت كل شهر كل شهر كل اسبوع كانوا
صواريخ كانوا صواريخ ليس 10 20 30 كل يوم
كانوا ثلاثه هون وخمسه هناك هذا كل الوقت
كل سنه كان ليس من من الحماس من من نظمه
ثانيه من جهاد وغيرها اما وبالنسبه لنا
هذا يعني م مستمر كل الوقت مستمر العملي
الارهابيه من الحماس واسرائيل تد سقوط
سقوط حكه الحماس في غزه هذا هذا في شروط
زي ما اقول في ثلاث شروط للمفاوضات مع مع
الحماس و الحماس ترفض كل الشروط نعم في
هذه الحاله سيد مصطفى سوف هل هل نفهم من
هذا السياق بان حركه حماس والمقاومه لم
تكن في في في سياق ان ان ان ان تخوض هذه
المواجهه بقدر ما اجبرت عليها نتيجه تقدير
معين من الحكومه الاسرائيليه لما يجري مع
القطاع يعني المقاومه الفلسطينيه وعلى
راسها كتائب القسام ليست معنيه بعدوان على
قطاع غزه وليست معنيه بهذه المواجهه ولكن
اذا فرضت المواجهه على المقاومه فانها سوف
تتصدى لهذا لهذا العدوان على القطاع انا
في ظني ان المقاومه جاهزه للرد على اي
عدوان بما لديها من امكانيات والمقاومه لا
تخدع نفسها وتعلم بان امكانياتها لا تقاس
الى جانب امكانيات الاحتلال الصهيوني
ولكنها في نفس الوقت تريد ان تدافع عن
كرامه شعبها وارضها امام هذا الارهاب
الصهيوني المتكرر هذا القصف الذي ياتي من
قبل المقاومه خلال الفتره الماضيه كان
نتيجه اعتداءات مستمره من قبل قوات
الاحتلال توغلات قصف بطائرات الاستطلاع
القيام بعمليات اطلاق نار باتجاه المناطق
الحدوديه المحاذيه لقطاع غزه مع فلسطين
المحتله من عام 48 فلذلك انا ارى ان حماس
هي الان ستدافع عن شعبها وهي ستخوض هذه
المعركه هي وكل فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي و وتقول للاحتلال
تفضل افعل ما تريد وكيف ما تريد وهذه امر
منطقي ان تدافع المقاومه عن نفسها وعن
ابناء شعبها نعم ولكن الا يخشى سيد ان
تكون المقاومه قد جرت لمواجهه لم تختر هي
توقيتها في حين ان اسرائيل ربما لحسابات
سياسيه داخليه هي من اختار ان تكون
العمليه بهذا الشكل وان تجهد مجموعه اشياء
من بينها حكومه الوفاق
الوطني يعني انا لا اعتقد ان المقاومه جرت
الى هذه المواجهه سبق وان وجهت المقاومه
تحذيرات الى الجانب الاسرائيلي ولكن على
ما يبدو ان الاحتلال لا يريد لقطاع غزه ان
يبقى يعني على الاقل يعيش في هدوء وهي
تريد ان كما اشرت تريد ان تقضي على
المقاومه لانها تعتقد بان المقاومه هي
التي تشكل العنصر الاساس في مواجهه
الاحتلال
وتحجيم وتقزيم مشروعه في القضاء على
القضيه الفلسطينيه وتصفيتها فلذلك حماس
ستواجه هذا القدر وستواجه هذا العدوان كما
واجهته هي وشقيقاتها من قوى المقاومه
المختلفه ل تصدي لهذا الارهاب الصهيوني
هذا قدر المقاومه وقدر الشعب الفلسطيني ان
يبقى شوكه في حلق هذا الارهاب الصهيوني
وان يبقى مدافعا عن ابناء شعبه عندما
يتعرضون للاعتداءات
والارهاب الصهيوني المتكرر نعم اذا بعد
الفاصل نريد ان نبحث خيارات سواء اسرائيل
او حماس لاداره هذا التصعيد الجديد على
قطاع غزه نرجو ان تبقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها التصعيد الاخير
على قطاع غزه سيد داني روبنشتاين كيف يمكن
لاسرائيل ان تتصرف في المستقبل القريب
خاصه وانها لا تريد ان تتورط بالكامل في
القطاع لكنها تريد في المقابل ان توجه
ضربات الى حد ما
مؤلمه
اولا ما في احتلال اسرائيلي في غزه
اسرائيل انسحبت من من كل قطعه غزه لحدود
67 وكان يعني اخلاء كل المستوطنات من من
قطعه غزه واليوم في يعني نحن نريد انا
بعتقد نحن نريد حكومه اسرائيل تريد وسطه
مصريه وهذا زي ما قلت ما في احتمال للاكت
خام لمشا دبابات اسرائيل لغزا في احتمال
وبيدخلوا على حدود
ا شيء صغير اما
ليس احتمال لاسرائيل وهلا يعني خدود القوه
ما في احتمال لاسرائيل لاقتحام ولتدخل
للزيك لل لل قطعه غزه في اليوم في قطعه
غزه في تقريبا 2 مليون سكان وهذا هذا
مشكله بصغير ما في ما في اي اي احتمال
للسيطره الاسرائيليه و احتلال اسرائيليه
على كتاه غزه هذا اولا ثانيا ونحن مع هذا
واضح منان حكومه اسرائيل و نحن امل في امل
في اسرائيل لتدخل مصريه عشان مشان الحكومه
المصريه حماس كان تصريحات من مصر من حكومه
مصر كان تخات ش حكومه حماسيه حكومه
ارهابيه هذا كان ليس من الحكومه اسرائيل
من حكومه الحكومه العسكريه المصريه و يعني
في اليوم في انا بعتقد في مشاركه بين
اسرائيل وبين مصر وفي مصلحه للمصر وفي
مصلحه لاسرائيل وفي تنسيق امني في صناع
وانا بعتقد في امل لو واقف هذا العمليه
وذا الفق الدام في في في في احتمال انا
بعتقد في امل لوقف هذا خلال اسبوع اسبوعين
وهذا ام هذا امل ولكن من كلام من كلامك
سيد روبنشتاين في هذه الحاله لا توجد
وساطه مصريه من كلامك ما يفهم بان هناك
تحالف مصري اسرائيلي ضد المقاومه وهذا
يختلف تماما عن
الوساطه مضبوط في في في يعني تفاهم بين
اسرائيل وبين
مصر حكومه الحماس وفي مصلحه لاسرائيل ولم
لسقوط لسقوط سيطره الحماس على على قتا غزه
وفي تفاهم وفي يعني هذا مصلحه مشاركه
لاسرائيل
لمصر سيد مصطفى صواف يمكن ان يكون هذا
الفهم موجود لدى المقاومه في ضوء ما كانت
تعانيه من حماس من نوع من الحصار مع مصر
وفي علاقاتها الدوليه مع ايران مع سوريا
وغير
ذلك انا لا اعتقد ان المقاومه يصل بها
الحد الى اتهام مصر بانها تنسق مع
الاحتلال الصهيوني لضرب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه رغم المواقف الغير مرضيه
للنظام المصري الحاكم الان باتجاه قطاع
غزه من استمرار الحصار هذه هذا الذي يتحدث
الان هو يحاول ان يعني يدق اسفين في
العلاقه
الفلسطينيه المصريه الراسخه رغم ان هناك
تعاون
بين الحكام في مصر وبين الجانب الاسرائيلي
فيما يتعلق في سيناء لان هناك قضايا ربما
تكون امنيه مشتركه بين الجانبين ولكن تبقى
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تبني علاقات طيبه مع
كل ابناء والامه العربيه والاسلاميه وخاصه
مصر التي هي الشقيق الاكبر لفلسطين وللشعب
الفلسطيني نحن نقول بان الاحتلال هو
احتلال دموي والاحتلال ليس بحاجه الى
تعاون وتنسيق مع مصر لكي يقوم بعملياته
الارهابيه وجرائمه وانا اعتقد ان هذه جزء
من عقيده يهود هو هذا الدم وا القتل وهذا
التدمير نحن نقول بان المقاومه ستتصدى
للاحتلال حال قيامه باي عدوان وهي الان
تتصدى ولو فكر الاحتلال الصهيوني الدخول
الى قطاع غزه اعتقد ان كل الشعب الفلسطيني
سيتحول الى مقاومه وعندها سيدخل الاحتلال
برجليه الى عش الدبابير وعندها سيصعب عليه
الخروج ولكن ولكن اسمح لي سيد مصطفى اسمح
لي سيد صواف هناك من هناك وجهه نظر تعتبر
بان هذه المواجهه رغم الخسائر هي محاوله
من حماس لاعاده تصدر المشهد في في الاشهر
الماضيه حماس توارت كانت تعاني نوع من
العزله لم اح لم يعد احد يذكرها كمقاوم و
الان ربما ما يجري الان في غزه فرصه
تاريخيه لاعاده تلميع نفسها
كمقاوم لو ارادت حماس تلميع نفسها للمعتم
بوسائل كثيره واعتقد ان المقاومه بالنسبه
لحماس استراتيجيه حماس ربما تراجعت خطوه
وراء للخلف لتقذف عر خطوات الى الامام هذه
قضايا تخطط لها حماس بطريقتها الخاصه
اعتقد ان حماس متجذر في الشعب الفلسطيني
تتقدم احيانا وتتاخر احيانا لتحقيق مصلحه
الشعب الفلسطيني وليس من اجل تلميع نفسها
او من اجل الظهور وكانها هي ال التي تحتل
المشهد حماس لازالت تحتل وسط الملعب
السياسي الفلسطيني ولا زالت لديها القدره
على احداث
هذا يعني الل في الساحه السياسيه بكل
اشكالها والوانها نعم في المقابل هناك
وجهه نظر سيد داني روبنشتاين تقول بان
نتنياهو الان يخضع لضغوط من من هم على
يمينه من المتطرفين
الاسرائليين الذين يريدون عمليه عسكريه
واسعه للقضاء نهائيا على البنيه التحتيه
لحماس كما يقولون هل تعتقد ان اسرائيل في
وارد ان تصل الى هذا المستوى في الفتره
المقبله
نعم انا يعني انا معك في درس كبير من على
حكومه اسرائيل على في كان كان يعني غدب
كبير باسرائيل بعد عمليه الارهاب من في في
خليل هذا في ثلاثه في خليل في يعني كان
غدب كبير في اسرائيل اما بالنسبه لخساره
لغزه هذا الخسار اولا هذا الخسار هذا ليس
خسار شامل في يعني اليوم كل لكهرباء
والنقود واكل بتيجي طريق اسرائيل بتيجي
للغزه ومين منين الخسار في مشاركه بالحصار
من من مصر يعني مصر هجمت حربت كل الانفاق
الانفاق في الحدود غفح من من يعني ضرب و
وسكر كل كل اغلقت كل الفاك هناك هذا حكومه
حكومه مصر وما في يعني معبر فاتح بال برفح
بين صنا وبين هذا كله يعني هذا موقف موقف
مصر مصر هي نفس
نفس وجهره نظر للحكومه المصر وحكومه
اسرائيل ضيد ضيد حكومه الحماس يعني انا
انا بعتك في راد في اسرائيل وفي يعني في
اسرائيل طلبوا كثير وكان ضط على حكومه
اسرائيل لل للضرب حماس لهجوم على حماس اما
زي ما اقول ما في في خ دود
للقوى وانا في عمل يعني لو وقفت لك النار
بعد اسبوع او اسبوعين نعم في انتظار هذا
الامل سيد مصطفى سواف كيف يمكن للمقاومه
ان
تستعيد الاجواء المعنويه للمقاومه ان صح
التعبير دون ان تجر القطاع الى مواجهه
اوسع مما يجري الان مع كل الخسائر التي
يبدو ان القطاع لم يعد يتحملها حتى
المواطن العادي لم يعد يتحملها رغم خطاب
المقاومه وادبيات
المقاومه يعني اعتقد المقاومه يعني لا
تريد ان تجر على قطاع غزه كما اشرت عدوان
واسع من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولكنها
في نفس الوقت لا يمكن ان تقف مكتوفه
الايدي امام هذه الاعتداءات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اكدت في عقاب عدوان 2012 اذا
التزم الاحتلال بالهدوء فهي ستلتزم
بالهدوء ولكن الاحتلال السسي خرق هذا
التفاهم وعاد للاعتداءات على قطاع غزه
فكانت ردود المقاومه واليوم هو يوسع هذا
العدوان بشكل كبير جدا ويرتكب حماقات
كبيره بحق ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني اما
المواطن الفلسطيني فانا اعتقد ان المشهد
الجاري الان في قطاع غزه يؤكد بان
المواطنين الفلسطينيين رغم كل ما يعانيه
من هذا الحصار ومن هذا العدوان هم خلف
المقاومه ومن يشاهد المواطن الفلسطيني وهو
يترقب او وهو يتابع سقوط الصواريخ ويذهب
الى المكان رغم طائرات الاحتلال في سماء
قطاع غزه حتى يمكن انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
يدلل على ان ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني يلتفون
خلف المقاومه نعم شكرا جليلا جزيلا لك سيد
مصطفى السواف الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
الفلسطيني كنت معنا من غزه شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من القدس داني روبنشتاين استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه غدا باذن الله قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد في امان الله